محمد ابراهيم باكستاني من ذوي الهمم بزغ
اسمه في لعبه تنس الطاوله في بلاده تغلب
محمد ابراهيم على وضعه الصحي وقد ولد بيد
واحده لكن ذلك لم يفت في عزيمته حيث قرر
ان يصبح لاعبا يشار اليه بالبنان في لعبه
تنس الطاوله
بدا شغفي بلعبه تنسى الطاوله منذ المرحله
الابتدائيه حينما نصحني مدرب اللعبه
بالبحث عن شيء اخر هذا ادخلني في تحد كي
اثبت قدرتي على اتقانها حيث حفزني ذلك على
ان اكون لاعبا ثم مدربا فكل شخص هباه الله
القدره على تحقيق ما يصبو اليه ان توفرت
لديه العزيمه والرغبه
ينحدر محمد ابراهيم من اسره متواضعه ورغم
الصعوبات فقد شارك في العديد من البطولات
المحليه والاقليميه المختلفه لفئات ذوي
الهمم بل شارك في عدد من البطولات
المفتوحه وتمكن بفضل صبره وتفانيه من حصد
العديد من الجوائز والميداليات
في بدايه مشواري كان والدي يتساءل عن جدوى
ما اقوم به لكن بعد ما حققته من بطولات
ذات يشعر بالفخر شاركت في بطولات محليه
واخرى في كوريا الجنوبيه ودبي ونلت عده
كؤوس ودروع وجوائز من بينها ثلاث ميداليات
ذهبيه وثلاث فضيات طموح محمد ابراهيم لم
يقتصر على اجاده لعبه تنس الطاوله بل بات
مدربا للعبه في احد المراكز الرياضيه في
مدينه بيشاور حيث درب ولا يزال العديد من
الاشبال والفكيه الذين فاز بعضهم في
بطولات على المستوى المحلي
شاهدت مقاطع لمحمد ابراهيم اثناء لعبه تنس
الطاوله حيث حفزني على هذه اللعبه ثم
اتصلت به وقررت التدرب معه والان بعد خمسه
اشهر تعلمت منه الكثير وشاركت في عدد من
البطوله الداخليه
يشتكي محمد ابراهيم من قله الدعم الحكومي
للانشطه الرياضيه لاسيما لذويهمم ويؤكد ان
بامكان اي شخص حتى وان كان من ذوي الهمم
تحقيق انجازات لا تقل عن الاخرين
لم يستسلم محمد ابراهيم لوضعها الصحي بل
قاده طموحه وتصميمه ليصبح لاعبا في تنس
الطاوله بل ومدربا وملهما للاخرين عبد
الرحمن مزيني لبرنامج صباح العربي بشاور